Erste prototypen die mit hilfe des sogenannten nano floss l konzepts angetrieben werden waren bereits auf den straßen der schweiz diese
elektroautos werden nicht mit hilfe einer batterie mit vielen zellen angetrieben sondern durch zwei
elektrolyt flüssigkeiten die über eine membran
elektrizität für den elektromotor
Erzeugen die einen feiern es die anderen zerreißen ist in der luft doch was ist wirklich dran an diesem
Hype ihr habt euch dieses thema beim az gewünscht wie man übrigens dazu kommt mehr am ende
Des videos und bekommt es auch jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die technik der fluss zellen batterie ist nicht neu sondern schon seit mitte des vergangenen jahrhunderts bekannt es gab auch schon
experimente bei der nasa die diesen energiespeicher
Konstruierte konkret geht es um eine art redox flow batterie hier zirkulieren sowohl ein elektrolyt mit positiver ladung als auch ein
elektrolyt mit negativer ladung in zwei getrennten kreisläufen durch eine membran
Findet 1 millionen austausch statt der dafür sorgt dass die e motoren angetrieben werden die vorteile liegen auf der hand diese fahren der batterie ist
preisgünstig und ermöglicht zudem große reichweiten in windkraft- und solaranlagen werden +10 schon seit einiger zeit zur stationären
Energiespeicherung eingesetzt doch diese konstruktion sind oft größer als mehrere autos doch dieses problem will das schweizerische unternehmen
name floss zell gelöst haben das verfahren sei reif für den serieneinsatz zitat
Mit der nano zell haben wir es erstmals geschafft eine fluss zelle auf die größe eines aktenkoffers zu reduzieren und
gleichzeitig die energiedichte der elektrolyte zu verzehnfachen
eine andere frau zählt ist der derzeit innovativste und leistungsfähigste energielieferant für mobile und stationäre
elektrische anwendungen die beiden verschiedene geladenen letzten flüssigkeiten werden in zwei separaten tanks gespeichert heißt also anders als bei herkömmlichen
batterien können die flüssigen elektrolyten
außerhalb der eigentlichen zelle gelagert werden das wäre der absolute wahnsinn statt
Stundenlang die eigene batterie zu laden fährt man an eine tankstelle und tankt
geladene
elektrolyt flüssigkeit
Revolutioniert wäre das und das würde nur ein paar minuten dauern
Im endeffekt ist das auch der entscheidende unterschied die gespeicherte energiemenge ist nicht mehr von der zellen größe abhängig
energiewandler und energiespeicher sind getrennt voneinander
Laut der offiziellen webseite ist die energiemenge die bereitgestellt werden kann abhängig von zwei faktoren zum einen von der elektrolyt
konzentration in der elektrolyt flüssigkeit und vom volumen der elektrolyt tanks beides könne aber an die
unterschiedlichen anwendungen angepasst werden nerviges und langes aufladen das gibt's nicht mehr sobald er
Mit flüssigkeiten verbraucht sind wird nachgefüllt was bedeutet das konkret für elektrofahrzeuge
eine bedeutende rolle spielt der filter der
der verbrauchten elektrolyt flüssigkeit die gelösten salze m zieht durch einen generator der durch die farbe energie angetrieben wird
Wird das übrig gebliebene wasser zu wasserdampf zerstäubt ab und an müssen die
Elektrolyt tanks natürlich aufgefüllt werden dazu heißt es auf der website mit
Nanotechnologie könnten allein, im straßenverkehr jährlich
1250 meter tonnen co2 emissionen aus der verbrennung
fossiler brennstoffe vermieden werden das sind 75 prozent der weltweit durch transport und verkehrt solchen co2
emissionen und die umwelt und
Nachhaltigkeits bilanz der produktion von name flow zählt sieht auch ziemlich gut aus wenn man den offiziellen angaben traut man verwende
rohstoffe die in großer menge verfügbar sein beziehungsweise
umweltverträglich gesundheits unbedenklich und
Nachhaltig gefertigt werden metalle seltener erden und metalle werden demnach nicht
Eingesetzt doch entscheidend dem themenbereich autos ist natürlich auch die leistung der vorteil hier selbst nach
10 tausend ladezyklen soll kein memoryeffekt
eintreten sagt dazu das versprechen der hersteller das bedeutet dass die nato zählt bis zu zehnmal mehr
ladevorgängen bewältigen kann als konventionelle
lithium-ionen-akku systeme
lithium-ionen-akku circa 1000 ladezyklen in einem automobil würde dies einer reichweite von rund zehn
millionen kilometern entsprechen und damit die lebensdauer eines modernen automobils bei weitem übertreffen
zusammengefasst also noch einmal für alle die jetzt ihren eigenen ohren nicht trauen konnten eine reichweite von 1000 kilometern
Kein problem die nach tankzeit grund vier minuten die batterie kaum altern mehr als 10.000
ladezyklen und ein beispiel aus der praxis wurde auch geliefert mit dem kleinwagen quandt tino der auf der
48 volt technik basiert und 2
159 liter elektrolyt tanks hat sei man mit bis zu 80 kilometer pro stunde mehr als 14 stunden
Am stück gefahren also alles viel zu schön um wahr zu sein oder lange jahre pries die firma nano
zell solche sensationellen daten und leistung werte an teilweise
vergleichbar mit supersportwagen auch die eigenen
studienergebnisse versprachen immer wieder neue sensationen doch lange dürfte niemand die sogenannten krank autos fahren die prototypen mit deutscher zulassung
fahren nur auf den straßen der schweiz den treibstoff und den tankvorgang wie man nicht öffentlich machen und die technischen daten scheinen
teilweise vor allem eines
unrealistisch und genau diese geheimniskrämerei
führte dann dazu dass immer mehr zweifel an der glaubwürdigkeit, des unternehmens aufgaben und das von allen seiten
Im oktober 2016 dann die wende die fachpresse war eingeladen zu einer ersten probefahrt
superkondensatoren die als strom puffer zwischen der fluss zelle und dem elektromotor geschaltet sind sollen eine beschleunigung von rund 5 sekunden
von 0 auf 100 stundenkilometer möglich machen eigentlich nicht möglich für ein fahrzeug mit einer masse von rund
1200 kilogramm in dem testbericht einer großen auto zeitschrift auto motor und sport vom 6 oktober
2016 hieß es dazu zitat die
versprochenen dynamik kann der fluss 10 flow auf dem testgelände nicht ganz beweisen aber trotzdem fährt er typisch elektroauto
ansatzlos zügig los auch zwei prototypen der großen automobilfirmen müssen bei der ersten fahrt kann sich abstriche gemacht werden immerhin der
Kantine absolviert seine erste ausfahrt völlig problemlos er wird zwar vernehmlich
Liegt aber und auf der straße und wirkt überraschend solide ja was die testfahrer also bestätigen konnten waren eher
grundsätzliche erkenntnisse die fahrzeuge werden von elektromotoren angetrieben und ihre reichweite passt um einen ganzen nachmittag zu fahren
zudem waren die fahrzeuge wohl gut und hochwertig
verarbeiteten abgesehen von der leistung wie sieht die infrastruktur
Aus eher mau es gibt noch keine einzige ladestation doch der technikchef des unternehmens nunzio
La vecchia ist optimistisch da die flüssigkeiten unbedenklich sein und keine hochdruck tanz braucht seien entsprechende
tankstationen leicht zu installieren zehn cent pro liter wurden mal als preis angegeben ob das tatsächlich
Realistisch ist halte ich jedoch bei allem optimismus
Für fraglich mittlerweile soll es weitere testfahrten mit japanischen ingenieuren gegeben haben wonach die autos ohne, nachtanken
1000 kilometer fahren konnten fest steht jedenfalls name float sein will gar nicht unbedingt ein autohersteller sein
Sondern sieht elektroautos nur als einen teil dennoch wenn alles stimmt was das unternehmen behauptet könnte die zukunft der e autos wirklich
bezahlbar sauber und nachhaltig sein und eines ist wichtig immer wieder gibt es scharlatane die mit absurden ideen
leichtgläubige investoren über den tisch ziehen aber es gibt auch revolutionäre technik die jahrelang von behörden und
alteingesessenen unternehmen blockiert wird ja immer ja nur an den brennwert kessel der einen viel höheren
wirkungsgrad als normale als heizkessel hat die abgase waren sogar kalt kein ingenieur
Wollte das glauben und dem erfinder wurden noch und noch steine in den weg gelegt heute
Ist der brennwertkessel fast in jedem haus befinden weil die technik einfach viel besser ist als die alte
Heizkessel technik es könnte also wirklich funktionieren ich bin jedenfalls extrem gespannt und wenn ihr immer als erstes neues zum thema
elektroautos und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir vom neuesten video direkt
Wenn es hochgeladen wurde garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von giggs und mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen oder
über abstimmungen mitbestimmen einfach
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch darauf klicken bald nur noch elektroautos technik vor
Technologiesprung da geht es um eine andere innovation ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran